- Let's sort of summarize
what we talked about.
I know there's a lot and there's
a lot more to talk about.
So I also included some
resources on the page,
if you wanna kind of
read more about data Viz
and linking as well to some
of my favorite color Viz
that is particularly inspiring
and just does a phenomenal job
of communicating different
aspects of the disease.
One of the biggest things we've seen
and I kind of kept harping on
is the
audience's responses to a visualization.
There's a lot we can't control
with how an audience is gonna perceive
or any given person is
gonna perceive a Viz
but it's the responsibility
to the designer to make sure
that the viewer has as much information
as possible and has
clear means as possible
to actually understand the graphic.
So much, like I feel like in science
we always talk about
alternative hypothesis
but alternative interpretations
are a huge part of data Viz.
So you might come into
a graphic thinking like,
well this is the way
you would interpret it
but it's your job to think like,
how else can this be interpreted
by someone who doesn't know
anything about the data
and it's just looking at my graphic?
The other aspect I've touched on as well
to accessible design.
So very simple things like
using color schemes
that are accessible for
people who are color blind
or even just something simple as like
making your font size big enough
is really critical for
people actually being able
to understand your Viz
and is that's a very I
think easy thing to do
if you're making Viz.
Much more difficult to deal
with is is cognitive bias.
So I hinted at this a bit,
but
the problem with a lot of COVID Viz
is people are coming in especially
because it's become so
politicized unfortunately.
People are coming into looking at Viz
with their own preconceived notions.
This applies to pretty much everything
but especially for COVID,
people come in thinking like,
well, I feel like it's not that bad.
You know, if you're
gonna come into looking
at a graph already kind of thinking like
this disease can't hurt me or
I'm invincible in some way,
or I already got some immune.
Whatever myths you wanna throw out there
that's going to be the framing
in with which you approach a Viz.
So the visualization designer job
is not to fight that cognitive bias,
but it is to present, you
know, as much information.,
so there's less fodder for that to be
kind of latched onto
and re reappropriated.
Of course, you can't control everything
stuff's gonna happen.
Grifters are gonna grift,
but you know you have to keep that in mind
for how people can can
take things out of context.
And the flip side too, right?
I think we often think about
that more kind of anti-science perspective
but people can also come into
things thinking, you know
this is how I've been told
this is supposed to work,
so that's the way it's gonna be.
Even if it's something like, I don't know
like for a long time where
there was very kind of
a conflicting data about the
spread of COVID in schools
it's still kind of unclear.
And a lot of people
went in and being like,
well, if it spreads here
is gonna spread everywhere
or kids can spread it
more easily than adults
and all kinds of narratives, right?
Like lots of quick distillations
to get clear pictures
of course, visualizing things like this
is extra precarious
because the data upon
which you're visualizing
often is conflicting.
And so that's something to
keep in mind when choosing
to make a visualization
for a piece of data
think about the data first.
And so this gets into another
point I wanted to touch on.
I'm just gonna jump down
to understand the data
because actually this is
really, really important.
I showed many different types
of data in these different graphics.
Something as simple,
a sensibly simple as COVID cases
can mean so many different things.
So the way in which a
COVID case is defined
can depend on department of health.
It can depend on
the person running the test.
It can depend on the country.
Like there are so many different
kind of caveats to that.
And so it's the absolute
responsibility at bare minimum
for someone designing a
visualization to really take
into consideration what the data
that they're actually showing is.
And so I'll get into this a
bit more for the coding video
but
when getting any kind of your data
it's your job to understand
like where did this data come from?
Who collected it?
How was it collected?
What's the quality of the data.
How are are metrics being defined
or calculated and things like that?
This is really like fundamental
to making any kind of visualization.
And oftentimes this is
the bulk of the work.
If you don't understand the data
you have no business
trying to visualize it
just as a kind of fact.
But oftentimes that's mostly work.
And the actual creation of the graphic
is maybe even less time,
but that's a huge part of data Viz.
And so the thing I've talked
about probably the most today
is providing context.
So
it's really probably the biggest problem
that visualization struggle with
in that they're often missing
or partially represented
to inject bias potentially.
Or if it's inadvertent
the bias is objected for them, right?
And so using annotations
like I showed you some
of the financial times graphics
is really cool and very, very helpful
for framing stuff for people, right?
Like little arrows and lines to be like
this is what this trend is,
and this is what this label is.
I know it's not very common
unfortunately in a lot
of science Viz but it's really
good for general data VIz
especially for something
as complicated as COVID-19.
Explaining labels and terms.
So saying something
like case fatality rate
without saying what that even
means is really problematic.
You have to say it like
this was calculated using
this metric and using these definitions.
And so yeah, that's very easy thing to do
but a lot of people don't do it.
Showing trends over time is
generally a good thing to do.
So I mentioned how
the Reuters Graphic
was showing those weekly aggregations.
A lot of other publications
we'll do seven day averages
which is something I will use as well
in the coding video as a
way to remove the noise
from
individual
days being potentially off
for randomly higher or low.
And you can misinterpret maybe a data dump
of cases as being like
an actual spike in cases.
For example, when maybe the reality is
the person inputting the
data took the weekend off
and waited to input like a
backlog of data from two days
on the following day.
So that that's something that
happens a lot unfortunately
especially in many many
different health departments
in the country.
But a one day number also just
showing someone like today
this number of cases happened
is also kind of problematic
because
it doesn't really mean much, right?
When you talk about a single day
when you're not comparing
it with the day before
or the day after.
It won't help viewers
understand the bigger picture.
And again reporting data issues
can affect single day numbers.
Another really important thing
is to keep your metrics consistent.
And it sounds really basic but
you know, I showed you
that kind of like messed up
why access before but mixing
different types of testing
for example, is a common thing people do.
That can be really misleading.
Some data Viz have these
manipulated axes to create
you know, maybe more extreme graphs,
others have compared
viruses to things like
the plague or Influenza
but then do
that over maybe like
disproportionate time lengths.
So,
like comparing six months of COVID data
to a year of Influenza,
doesn't sound like a huge
difference, but it actually is.
That's double the time
with which, you know
the disease can spread
and you know, go around a population.
So yeah, keeping comparisons
as comparable as possible.
And that gets into as well the
sort of normalization thing
for population as well, too.
So keeping population
as limited as a compound as possible.
Population is important but
it's important in the sense
in that it can help calculate
like per capita type changes.
So when you're comparing States,
cities, regions in general
the number of people matter,
more than that actually the
people themselves matters.
So demographics change as well too.
So it's rare to see this but
it's actually good practice
to probably correct for things like age
and racial diversity to see.
You actually,
if you look for those things
and normalize across population
that way
you can start to pick out differences
in
maybe like severity of the disease,
hitting different populations
which is something that
actually did come out
when the spread of COVID
was more carefully studied
across different race groups in America.
And the most important thing I think
that is not so often done.
I think that New York Times
piece did that really well,
was to acknowledge the uncertainty
and limitations of the data.
So, right.
I think understanding
what we don't know,
understanding what isn't shown,
is something that is inherently
very, very hard to do.
It kind of gets back to my
initial point earlier of
kind of communicating a certainty
is the most difficult thing to do
especially because people are expecting
clear cut simple straightforward answers.
But this is the kind of
of responsibility of the
visualization designer.
So something like adding a note section
at the end of the Viz,
including some additional texts
to kind of clarify some
points or saying like,
oh on these two days, data is missing
and so to handle that,
we like removed these
days from the calculation.
Easy thing to do.
But the kind of scope of those limitations
and the scope of the uncertainty
kind of as they grow,
it makes it harder to actually make a Viz
that's compelling.
So that's also something you weigh
when you even decide to to make your Viz
in the first place.
Making COVID Viz
in this day and age
is it's something that's
really important still.
We're still very much the
midst of this pandemic.
I thought the study was like pretty cool,
they took
a little over 5,000 COVID visualizations
from April to May
of this past year,
specifically from Twitter.
And they were about COVID-19
and tried to look at potential challenges
with how things were framed.
And a lot of this is stuff
I just mentioned, right?
Cognitive bias, not
really getting the virus.
Yeah,
these are problems that
I think all data Viz
has to deal with.
And I think the fact that
mistrust is so high here
just kind of
highlights just
how
kind of messy
the audience is
in terms of putting in you COVID Viz.
So many people are
distrustful of data sources
and so being as transparent
and as explicit about where
the data is coming from,
is really, really key to
kind of conveying something
with your Viz if you're
going to put something
out there in the public
The information
that is in any given Viz sometimes
like it's intentionally scared
and that breeds, you know
that kind of mistrust.
And so right, these are just some
the top things researchers found as being
like the biggest challenges
with Viz
on Twitter
which is unfortunately a place where a lot
of people share, share COVID Viz.
Some of it's great and some
of it is very much not.
So,
it's oftentimes hard to
parse those differences.
And on an awesome note,
there is so much like
phenomenal COVID Viz out there,
like truly inspiring.
This is just a small sample of it
and the links will be on the page two
but
yeah,
some of this I already showed
from the New York Times
and the Washington post
the financial times
but they all their teams have made
incredible, incredible other stories.
Visualizations, interactives.
I wanted to also highlight
a couple other ones
from the Reuters Graphics team.
They did this really
compelling piece on one woman
in Korea who seated their
biggest COVID-19 cluster
this is in South Korea,
and the kind of story telling flow
of that piece was really remarkable.
Even more kind of innovative.
Shirley Wu did this.
I worked with a team of people
to create a literal game
to kind of simulate
different conditions around
public health measures
and situations around.
Again, sort of a fake disease
but in a pandemic situation
people with the pandemic game.
So there's like a lot of
really, really fun Viz out there
and so don't feel like, you know
you need to like replicate
anyone else's work or anything
but it's really inspiring.
And so if you wanted to take time to learn
about how to do COVID Viz,
I think looking at their work
is a really inspiring place to start.
And yeah,
it's completely okay to make Viz
on your own time
and build kind of skillsets
and get feedback from
others until you're ready
to make your own
visualizations in general.
It doesn't have to be of COVID-19
cause hopefully COVID-19 visualizations
won't be as prominent of a
thing in the next year or so.